What's the best time of day to take glutamate scavenger?
I can't remember if you suggested this because of the paddock attacks I'm still having in the late afternoon at evening.
Yeah, so glutamate scavenger, I probably did recommend it for the paddock attacks because I think
we discussed the possibility of paddock attacks and anxiety being tied to excess glutamates in the brain.
So remember, so what causes anxiety? What causes paddock attacks? What causes OCD issues? What causes depression?
Issues, it's brain inflammation. So it depends on where that brain inflammation is. What part of the brain
their inflammation exists and it's going to give you different symptoms. Even pain can be from
brain inflammation. So remember your brain, you have different lobes in the brain, the front behind
your forehead as your prefrontal cortex. It's your executor of the brain that tells the rest of the
brain what to do. That tells that's where your thought process is. That's where your personality is.
But then that's where your decision-making is. That's why it's called the executive function of the
brain and it sends messages back to your pre-motor cortex and then to your motor cortex which
performs function of movement. If you're going to move your hand, you have to fire back into those
centers. The OCD issue and the paddock issue has to do with a deeper part of the brain, part of the
brain called the amygdala. These are called more sensory parts of the brain that store memories that
store more primitive function in your body. This is where your sympathetic and parasympathetic
nervous systems are stored. These are part of your autonomic nervous system, meaning automatic. It's
not something you think about. You don't think heart beat faster, heart beat faster, or liver detox
faster, or liver detox faster. You can make your liver detox faster by your executive prefrontal cortex
function. It's done by a deeper part of your brain. If you have inflammation in any parts of these
centers of the brain, you're going to have symptoms. The outside top of your brain, you have your
pride alums. That's what sends back sensory functions. That's where you'll feel pain, heart cold,
stingly sensation. If you have inflammation up there, you're going to have pain elsewhere in the
body. I have knee pain all the time. Could it be caused from the knee itself, your damage of knee?
Sure. Could it be caused from inflammation in the brain? Yes. Nothing to do with the knee whatsoever.
So, brain inflammation affects your whole body. So, panic attacks, same thing. There's brain
inflammation. But the other thing I said about panic attacks and anxiety and OCD, it can be because
of neurotransmitter imbalance. Anytime it's because of inflammation, but that neurotransmitter imbalance
would be excess glutamate. The excitatory neurotransmitters in your brain are glutamate as your primary
one. Dopovine can be as well, can serotonin can be as well, and epinephrine can be as well. But
glutamate is your primary one that can get out of balance. It tends to get out of balance
partly because of our diet, because our food sources are filled with glutamates, exogenous glutamates
that are meant to stimulate this pathway. They literally put glutamates in food so that when you
eat that food, the glutamate connects to your tongue, the sense of fires, a glutamate sensation to your
brain and you get an excitatory neurotransmitter response to that food. And that's what can make you say,
wow, this is really good. I just love this Chinese restaurant or whatever it is because of the glutamates
that are in there stimulate that your neurotransmitters in your brain fire excess glutamate up tick your
brain. You get excitatory neurotransmitter function in your brain and you think that the food tastes
better. Though it's simply a glutamate response tricky, huh? Well, we have all sorts of exogenous
glutamates in our food, but we also can have defects on our GAN pathways where we convert
glutamine, which is an amino acid, followed in all sorts of proteins. We can convert that to
glutamate quicker with that defect. And we can be more prone because of that to end up producing
excess glutamate in our brain. And then we have we're more prone to OCD issues and panic attack issues.
Then it can seem more complicated. You have what you reinforce neurological pathways in your brain
by those pathways firing more often. So the more you fire a pathway, the more that pathway is
reinforced. I explained it as as kind of like if you have a gravel road, but it's being traveled on
a lot, they're going to payment and then they're going to turn it into a two-lane four-lane six-lane highway.
That's kind of what happens in your brain when you when you are when that pathway is being fired. So
even in the past, you're exposed to a lot of glutamates that OCD pathway or that panic attack pathway
by pain stimulating that that neurological pathway that then is more easily traveled because it's
turned into a highway. That is exactly what from a neurological standpoint in the simplest terms is
how you describe PTSD as well. So you had this horrible experience and then anything that triggers it
triggers that experience again and you basically are repainting that pathway. So glutamate scavenger
product it's called glutamate scavenger two that I typically recommend can help pull glutamates
out of your brain. It was a very long answer to when should I take this? So when you should take it is
when you experience those attacks or if you know you start getting more of those attacks, let's say at
three o'clock maybe at two o'clock at hour before is the time to get that into your system to reduce
those attacks.